all right because
[Music]
that we've been covering pay attention
to this hand
what it does to his head okay so
remember he was going forward and it
goes in this Loop forward
without the entrance
again without the answering pay
attention with your juicy Potter
here
that's the same figure do it on his head
his head does the same pattern but the
mechanism is on the outside of my arm on
the upper outside of my arm come to this
right hand
right here
and on this side of his head
so the other one it was here he goes
forward I go like this
this time it's here but his head does
the same thing
[Music]
okay so look for that as I do that the
same technique
right there
[Music]
not here
has to come around and forward
[Music]
not here
he touches
and around forward
where does he touched you make him touch
you position yourself
and you bring him to it
put yourself there and then put him
there
who's here
not there no
in forward
let's try
okay so uh just like this part here oh
that's an adhesion
[Music]
I'm not grabbing him
same exact thing here clearly I can't
grab them I have that Ikea adhesion here
so you have to match the yarn very uh
value and then it goes
this is exact same
now let's work on this second element
the second element is we're going to
over emphasize the grounding of the back
foot
so my back foot
will not move
no
[Music]
okay try
so all all of that stuff you see
all this stuff your mind is not settled
your Qi is not sunk you get it you're
pushing on him that's why you're getting
pushed off
so pull settle
settle
um
all right
thank you
[Music]
settle
okay try it again